Uruguay's the country famous for soccer.
As we celebrate Russia's,
we'll see this summer we've checked the
whole fame and there are only eight
countries that have ever want to final
year grier,
really small country with a little more
than 3 million inhabitants while there
one of them,
they've even won the cup twice and in
both cases they beat their need as
Brazil and Argentina.
Tina.
So in today's video we're going to talk
about how Uruguayan has beaten then
neighbors,
but not in soccer,
but rather in economics.
Yes,
alongside Chile.
Uruguay is the wealthiest country in
America when it comes to GDP per capita,
but it's also one of the most stable
when it comes to politics and that has
some of the best public services,
but there's even more to this story.
We can actually say that Uruguay is the
model for the entire South American left
wing.
Have you ever heard about their former
presidents seem weaker?
He's known as the world's poorest
presidents and he quickly became the
ultimate leftwing or rockstar.
He's the only world leader.
We refuse to live in the presidential
palace and kept driving an old
Volkswagen instead of an expensive
official car.
From a life philosophy perspective,
I believe it's better to live little
luggage,
just the minimum necessary,
no material complexity.
If you have too much complexity,
you end up spending too much time.
Nevertheless,
while knew who kind of has this simple
lifestyle,
his country grew economically,
it's attracted foreign companies and it
became a pioneer with social rights with
me here as President Uruguay passed a
bill for the legalization of same sex
marriage.
That's undoubtedly his most famous
policy was the legalization of
recreational marijuana sales way before
California or any other country.
Uruguayan was the first country to
legalize the sale and consumption of
wheat and the country's progress.
It doesn't stop them.
If you take a static picture of Uruguay,
you will see a country.
There's arguably is the best place to
live in all of South America.
If you take a static picture of Uruguay,
you will see your country.
There's arguably is the best place to
live in all of South America.
Unlike Brazil and Argentina,
Uruguay is economy hasn't stopped
growing since 2000 and to have a
thriving middle class since the highest
wages in the region along with Chile,
but hold on a minute because not
everything is a field of roses.
ROSACEA.
In fact,
as such a prosperous country,
you might expect it to have plenty of
immigrant.
Right?
Well,
the reality is actually ready
difference,
and this is not because they have strong
immigration laws,
people just don't pick a Uruguayan as a
country of residence because well,
things are actually starting to go
rather sour.
They have around an 80 percent
unemployment rates and that economic
growth speed is reducing.
Well.
Other countries like Peru and Chile
seemed to offer opportunities for
everyone.
So today's question is why has
Uruguayans economy worked out so well
until now?
Ones.
What are the current problems they're
facing?
Well,
today we're going to answer all of those
questions,
but before we do,
let's take a look back at the history
America.
Switzerland.
Uruguayan was born in 1830 after a war
between Brazil and Argentina,
the British words and negotiate the
peace agreements,
and they badly wanted Uruguay required
to be an independent country.
Sorry.
Why was this?
Well,
Montevideo is harbor was a jewel and
they didn't want it ending up in
Brazilian or Argentinian enhance back
then Uruguay.
It was almost uninhabited.
It was inhabited by a tribe called the
Cero [inaudible],
but they were soon exterminated.
This is why unlike many other South
American countries and most of
Uruguayans have a European ethnicity,
mainly Spanish and Italian roots in
those times,
if you are an ambitious boy looking for
a career and an opportunity to make
money,
Uruguay was the place to go.
It was better than America and it was
better than Australia.
It was a modern democracy with rule of
law and a thriving.
Yeah.
Economy
until the sixties of the 20th century.
This country was among the wealthiest in
the world.
It was way richer than many European
nations.
In fact.
So now you might be wondering,
well,
what exactly happens?
Because despite being prosperous among
South American nations,
Uruguay is still way behind any European
country,
let alone America.
So what happens to make them stop
growing so dramatically?
Well,
the answer lies in the whole things.
The European Union.
Yep.
You heard me right?
Devita.
If you thought this idea of a trade war
was donald trump's invention on the very
mistaken in the year 1958,
the European single market was created
and one of the first things they did was
to protect their agriculture from
neat
meant that rule quite lost their biggest
customer.
The United States didn't want to trade
with them either.
It was in the middle of the Cold War and
they were too busy dealing with bigger
problems than this little country to pay
attention.
So Day by day Uruguayan became stagnant
and it's the government's in Montevideo,
the country's capital.
They didn't have any other alternative
than to look to their neighbors.
Argentina,
all of a sudden,
Uruguay and Argentina became something
like the Robert Rodriguez and Quintin
Tarantino of South America.
Argentina had a financial crisis,
so did Uruguay.
If Argentina had a military
dictatorship,
well suited Uruguay,
Argentina had a democracy.
Well,
yes,
so data Uruguay.
So Dev you are well what happens in
Argentina in the year 2002?
Well,
they have the biggest financial crisis
in all of history.
The now in famous Carlita ends in the
very same year.
Uruguayans GDP fell by seven point seven
percent,
which was a big time catastrophe.
And this was when I realized they had to
find new trade partners,
but how would they do that?
Well,
let's look into it.
Zero kilometer of South America during
the 19 eighties,
Uruguayan returns to democracy and the
government did something really,
really interesting.
They created the so called Zonis
frankness.
These were special territory's inside of
the country where companies were free to
not pay taxes,
no VAT,
no income tax,
no corporate tax.
The only request was that 75 percent of
the jobs that are given to locals.
Maybe this reminds you of something
because it's pretty much the same idea
as the special economic zones that exist
in China that we liked so much here at
visual Polish,
sick
or acquire has 11 tax freeze,
the three d
different kinds.
First we have those oriented to
logistics and international trade.
After that we have the zones that are
designed for attracting multinational
corporations that can use them as the
headquarters for the South American.
Finally,
we have the areas that are meant to have
high tech industry and this is why or
requires a regional leader and things
such as pharmaceutical research and
software,
but this is not the end of the story.
These tax free zones have a unique
advantage.
Something that makes Uruguay a model for
other countries.
Yes,
if you are here,
we're talking about political stability.
In the year 2005 Uruguayan changed its
government leadership and they had lost
a left wing presidents that would be to
bad Vasquez from the open friends party.
You see in most South American
countries,
having such an ideological shift in the
government means that most of the work
made by the previous administrations,
something goes into the trash.
Okay,
so you might think that under a brand
new left wing government,
those tax resigns would no longer exist.
Rice.
Well,
the reality,
it actually couldn't be more different.
And this is the great thing about this
country,
the bipartisan consensus.
This is why between 2005 and 2014,
the accumulated investment in these tax
free zones rose to almost $6,000,000,000
and all of this happens while first
Vasquez and then Jose Mojica managed the
country.
She will keep them here for not looking
only for profit.
They also want safety and this is what
roadway has to offer.
It's not a matter of this or the other
government.
He is a genuine attitudinal neck.
The emily one's a well,
what does Uruguayan get from these tax
free zones?
Well,
that is a double benefits of them.
Actually.
On the one hand,
they are able to appeal to industries
that otherwise would have set up in
other countries with bigger markets and
these foreign companies need providers.
This is why sooner than expected,
many small enterprises are created
around the country and of course they
require highly skilled labor and that
means good salaries.
This is why Uruguayans do need to
emigrate in order to find a good one
job.
The
of the moments here,
because we said that Uruguayan needs to
change trade partners,
right?
Maybe you remember how we said that they
could no longer depends on Argentina or
Brazil for their exports,
so you might not be wondering,
well,
what did the tax free zones have to do
with all of this?
Well,
just think about it.
Thanks to these innovative industries
that set up in the country.
Uruguayan could stop relying on the
commodity of sex prior to this.
Their economy was based mainly on it and
don't meet today.
They create products that have more
value added.
Giving you an example.
All of the Syrup and he did in Pepsi
drinks sold across all of South America
is created in Uruguay.
In fact,
there's a particular type of Pepsi in
Japan called Pepsi Zukie.
This is made with a plant called sweet
theme,
and again,
the Sarah for this beverage is produced
a 200 kilometers away from Montevideo in
total.
Pepsi represents seven percent of
everything.
The country exports,
and this is not the only example,
one of the biggest papermaking companies
on the planet,
a Finnish company called UPM has one of
them main factories in Uruguay and
they've already announced the
construction of a brand new facility
that might represent a whole two point
five percent extra GDP for the country,
and if that isn't enough,
Uruguay is also a software leader
or acquiring software developers among
the best in all of Latin America.
In summary,
30 percent of Uruguay's exports are
produced from these tax free zones,
and yes,
here's the main buyer here.
Well,
let me give you a clue.
It starts with a C and h and I,
and it ends in an A.
Nowadays Brazil and Argentina received
just 20 percent of this country's
exports.
I don't think a friend of your required
is the Netherlands.
The Rotterdam harder is the gateway to
Europe as many of the Uruguayan exports
go that way to make a comparison.
Chili's economy,
despite being the wealthiest in the
region,
is heavily reliant on that copper
mining,
half of their exports of this commodity
alone Uruguay.
Instead,
it's got a diversified economy.
We've talked about software,
paper drinks,
and of course cy and nice,
but if you thought of everything is all
sunshine and rainbows and hold on a
second,
it's because things are not quite as
perfect as you might think.
Party versus government,
as we said before,
since the year 2005 Uruguay has had a
left wing governments,
more specifically,
this country has been managed by the
Open Front Party and one thing is
certainly true.
They are worthy of that name because it
is really an open policy with plenty of
different ideologies inside.
This is why despite what it looks like,
arguments a pretty common thing in the
potty.
So on the one hand,
despite the different presidents,
why hasn't the same finance minister for
the last 30 years?
His name is denny Louis' story and you
could say that he's one of the
architects of this Uruguayans too,
but on the other is the open front
is really a battle fronts between the
radical wing as the moderate wing
champions by two that Vasquez hosting me
because the left wing Rockstar,
he's somewhere in the middle and this is
why anytime Uruguayan government wants
to sign a free trade deal with any other
country,
they must face that own party
opposition.
It happens during the first Vasquez
administration when they tried to sign a
deal with the United States.
It happens when they tried to sign a
deal with Chili and it might not happen
as they want to sign a deal with China.
In Atlanta,
Emilia,
2018,
we will mark the 30 years of diplomatic
relations with China and this is why we
have put this date as a deadline to sign
a free trade deal.
In this case,
Uruguayan companies would save more than
$100,000,000
in needless tariffs,
but this radical wing of the open front
seems to be allergic to the word free
trade,
and if this was not enough,
some critics claim that Daniella a story
the finance minister spends to missile.
Yeah,
this is actually one of the biggest
problems in IRC required after Venezuela
and Argentina,
Uruguay has the largest share of civil
servants in the region.
One out of five workers is employed by
the government,
and if you add to this the enormous
presence of an illegal economy,
you'll understand why just one third of
adults work for private companies in
most developed nations,
this number is more than half.
Of course,
compared with Argentina or Brazil.
Uruguay is a paradise on earth,
but the truth is if they wanted to keep
growing,
they must solve these problems as soon
as possible.
Sorry.
Now the final question is,
do you think Uruguay should sign those
free trade deals?
Do you think it is still worth investing
in as a country?
Well,
please leave your answer in the comment
section below,
and as always,
please visit our
friends@reconsidermedia.com.
That's the podcast that provided the
vocals in this episode that we're not
mine,
and also don't forget to support us on
patrion where you can get access to
exclusive content and if you like this
video,
please do give us a thumbs up and as
always I'll see you next time
and if you want to learn more about
politics and hear even more of my left
before you can join us at reconsider
media,
we have a podcast@reconsideredmedia.com
slash podcast.
See you.